this is screen junkies boobie pies
brought to you by loot crate now your
host and he's ignored green screen
junkies welcome to another episode of
movie fights I'm so excited
today's give me a fantastic fight we
have an amazing guest and two amazing
guess you already know today I'm so
actually just have to say I'm glad to be
back because Nick Mundy took over the
show two weeks ago wow that was intense
good job Nick I stand by his ruling I
don't agree with his always as rounds
but I think I'm accent did fight Monday
boy overnight Monday fight good job Nick
thanks for holding seat he was homeless
he cuz we were in Chicago at Wizard
World had amazing joke I'm with the
right crowd on this I was gonna wear my
bullet club shirt I didn't at the last
second and now I feel I'm sorry I'm
gonna introduce in a second but you may
not know you're getting excited cuz I'm
excited but let me do some clean up
quick Nick money was here because we
were in Chicago at Wizard World and
thank you guys so much for coming that
was amazing
I hope you enjoyed that show we have so
much fun stuff today including an honor
of force Friday what's the best movie to
I ever made will be pitching ultimate
Man of Steel sequels and so much more
fun stuff so at any point during the
show if you don't like something we're
talking about don't leave just click on
the bottom right hand corner pick your
fight and you can see all this stuff
we'll be talking about in today's
episode as always we're in iTunes as
well so check us out there but let's get
to who's here and I'm so excited first
up you know him he's a screenwriter of
American ultra chronicle and the
upcoming Victor Frankenstein which looks
awesome you've requested him we've been
wanting him I'm so happy is here it's
max landis it's really it's really me
you're really here I can't believe it
but we've had people bothering you to be
on this I have for for a year I'm so
grateful you came by and we could make
it happen I was anxious about it because
the main thing people are mad at me for
generally is that I express opinions
don't don't we don't take things out of
context here there's the end my career
starts now next to him he's a favor of
the show the head writer of honest
trailers and on his game trailers
Spencer Gilbert
[Applause]
Charlie Feldman oh yeah yeah always
great and chloe dykstra was on this show
Wow he was here all my life
mutual friends yes thanks friend me back
good job Spencer next to him we love her
she's the co-host of profile it's the
red fury herself I wish I'm alone hello
I'm gonna get slotted today quite weird
shows different shows we wanted to bring
some awesome fighters today we've done
it I'm excited as any great show as
always on the Dan cam it's Mr Dan
Morelle how are you doing good I don't
think we're not yeah I haven't done this
in a while yeah it's been like a month
so it's good to be back over here and I
should I should introduce you to next to
you next to you so April Donnell April
fought on the Chicago show on the fan
fights and guys cut back to me please
guys you were very mean you were too
mean you guys didn't understand April
had an unfair thing we had four fans in
Chicago come up and take on the best
fighters we have and these fans
literally had no idea no prep time it
literally just came in to do it and I
was so grateful to all the fans but
April was in town we wanted to bring her
back I just wanted to apologize on
behalf of some of the mean comments that
were said you didn't have any time to
prep correct April correct but I thought
you did a great job everybody need a
drop and I heard you did catch up you
you know you're Scorsese but you weren't
as unknown in your early season you've
sense caught up correct yes I went and
watched Goodfellas which was incredible
I'm definitely missing out good so see
people be nice and I'm glad you caught
up and now you're caught up in how
awesome he is we know so guys be nice
April thank you for coming this is very
fun we're glad to have you here and just
overall just be nice people right we're
gonna be nice to people
oh you come try it angry comedy you you
come to come find us at a convention and
you comes fight us invite the anger we
gathers don't be mean to our fans we
love your fans you guys rock that's
right wait wait you guys like getting
nice comments on YouTube who died should
have never had me
I mean to you know be nice and Max
people were honored this year all right
get ready you're going it's a Jacob's
Ladder leveled I'm excited people people
despised me before one more thing before
we start I want this shirt if you made
me this is tough shirt Romeo I don't
have to say your last name Stratos strap
strata Dodi good offense grad sealed
ravioli Romeo
thank you man I've gotten a wearing at
pride I'm so excited that was amazing of
you thank you for sending this to me
from Europe that was expensive to print
this the European XL is a little tight
but I'm doing it for you buddy uh thank
you so much
also one last thing before we have to
show stay tuned for the very end of the
show we have a very special guest next
week we're super excited about so stay
tuned to reveal that I don't want to
take away from our amazing guest now
ouch ouch bro I'm saving at the end
because we're happy but just stay tuned
at the very end I'm gonna tell you
something else max is excited - I know
he is so she Shh yeah walls reminder as
we know I'm basing the argument on your
passion your creativity and your points
like the facts if you make a fact wrong
dance there - correct
or if you have a question we can ask but
he's there to always check what we're
doing all right I have a question yes on
this show because it's a debate show
should I be expressing my opinions like
they're fact or should I should I say do
that because there's no everybody knows
there's no such thing as a good movie I
think you want you want to tell you want
to tell us why they're wrong and why
yours is the best why I be a little boy
I feel they're wrong but you're making
noise yes it's all about twisting and
making sure there's honest
argument I'm a [ __ ] different
opinions
I'll kill your family no I'm not you
don't know what I'll do now before we
fight I have to do a quick call out to
our wonderful sponsor lootcrate dan is
holding some amazing items from the last
month dan look at this you got a carnage
bug a los Pollos hermanos I'm cooking up
some great sponsor floods dan is showing
off some amazing items as if you don't
already know they deliver pop-culture
items to your door for less than $20 a
month you'll get the latest apparel
collectibles and exclusive items at loot
crate has to offer and Dan is showing
off some of them awesome ones I like the
Hydra pin you have - yeah I've got a
Hydra pin Wow
if you sign up quick next month is the
summon crate as they celebrate monsters
you can fit your pocket items from
blizzards supernatural Kidrobot etc plus
an exclusive collectable at loot crate
says is the most important object pretty
much in the whole universe is that the
Infinity Gauntlet I don't know they they
won't tell us send any stones sub maybe
something good anyway go to loot crate
comm slash movie fights use the code
movie fights to save 10% on any new
subscription and don't forget supporting
loot crate supports the show so thank
you so much loot crate awesome job Dan
my van away thank you alright
round one this is actually a movie
fights rematch from episode 10 can you
believe it's been like 47 coming up on a
year we're going back because we have so
many fun fights we've done we're
bringing some back in this arena action
this is episode 10 totally 80s for the
win on Twitter asked us what would be
the ultimate movie crossover
okay so if you can combine two movies
that wouldn't normally be able to be
there what would they be in Spencer
we're starting with you what's your pick
all right I'm gonna combine two things
that I love it's already happened in the
comics but I want to see it on film that
is the Marvel Universe and I'll call it
the zombie universe
take your pick a zombies
you get 28 days later zombies down to
the dead it doesn't matter whatever it
is it's the catalyst to one of the
Marvel superheroes getting bit and we
have a super-powered zombie infection
and this is gonna kick off what I some
of my favorite comic stories which are
the weird one-off comic stories the
weird mini series that's like what if
all the Marvel guys were around in the
1600 so what if Superman landed in
Soviet Russia this is what if all the
Marvel superheroes were zombies and it's
like a Sam Raimi funny horror movie
they're all devouring each other the
funniest part is that they have their
superhero personalities when they're
full so they're in character but then as
they get hungry and hunger they turn
back into these killer bloodthirsty
zombies so you have Steve Rogers you
know devouring Bucky Barnes I'm sorry
buddy I'm sorry I didn't mean to do it
but he can't help himself all the
zombies take over the world some of the
superheroes are our holdouts I think
this would really be a shot in the arm
to both and I'm not going to say stale
genres but both genres they could use
some fun new twists interesting to take
Alicia what's your take well I really
loved Mission Impossible rogue nation
and I can't wake for Specter so I would
love to see Mission Impossible and James
Bond do a crossover the American spy
Ethan Hunt and the British spy James
Bond
Ethan Hunt cos played by Tom Cruise
James Bond played by Daniel Craig I
think they're both evenly matched they
both use brains and brawn they're both
used technology they're both great with
the ladies and they're both not afraid
to go off book and go rogue and get the
job done so I love these two to match up
to take on each other maybe they're both
going after the same case it could be
like a Batman vs Superman kind of
situation and I just think that was
really interesting yeah well I'd love to
see ya versus because I'd love to see
who would win who would be the better
spy got it max is your turn this time
breakfast break so do i rebuff there's
now okay so it can be anything I want
right okay so it's 1996 I really want a
lethal weapon crossover with literally
any established movie franchise those
two characters inject heart humor a very
specific tone into almost anything they
do as shown
the varying types of villains they face
within the movies so I'm going to pitch
you straight up right now lethal weapon
vs predator now you might say Danny
Glover was already in predator 2 almost
universally reviled movie the predator 2
actually had a lot of good ideas the
idea of a predator in an urban
environment is already compelling
certainly more compelling because it
would be dealing with a wider variety of
people than simply an elite commando
team which if you watch the first
predator more than once you know doesn't
go well however when the predator is out
of his world and into ours merton rigs I
mean the dialogue in this movie writes
itself
act 1 Japan you know the [ __ ] socks
out I don't know race he tore its spine
out that to me seems like some kind of
serial killer Martin it's always a
serial killer with you everything's a
serial killer everything's a pattern
killer you investigate these things and
it's nothing I saw worse stuff than this
and nom it's not gonna be a big deal
we'll have it done by the end of week
second act just a flying around those
[ __ ] lays in the spear rigs you have
to listen to me what we're seeing here
it's a plasma weapon it's either
experimental possibly maybe
extraterrestrial I've heard about these
things rigs you hear about them out in
New Mexico Roger come on come on I
confess it's strange
I confess there's something weird going
on but extraterrestrial the only thing
out moving out of this world around here
is your daughter's body am i right
Rick's what what'd you say Thanks yeah
you did you said you're still mad about
that that was in Lethal Weapon 3 come on
leave it alone okay so so then act 3
that were 22 Jump Street stole it from
its I'm replacing Lethal Weapon 4 with
this movie God direct those 96 what
wasn't in 90 tiny 6 ok gotta know gently
your Chris Rock no I'm replacing the Jet
Li fight at the end of Lethal Weapon 4
with them physically fighting a predator
because because what's the best part of
Lethal Weapon 4 which is not a shitty
it's just not as good as the rest the
fight at the end with Jet Li which is
about Brotherhood is about friendship
has an incredible emotional payoff of of
Rogers swimming down and refusing to
give up on him
you know the emotional core of the
Lethal Weapon movies is pure and strong
and well executed and well acted and
smart and predator is just a cool idea
he's just a cool idea you had any cool
idea
to a lethal weapon movie or add the
lethal weapon characters in tone to any
cool idea you get something worth saying
you think lethal weapon versus
terminator wouldn't be a great movie
you think the lethal weapon you think
lethal weapon with et wouldn't be a
great movie I can go further
you think lethal weapon in Inception
wouldn't be way better you think lethal
weapon well let's ask these guys what do
you think yeah so lethal weapon for what
is Joe Pesci and along for the ride well
I have done a lot of research they've
been coming for you conspiracy theorists
except for them in the middle of a
second act he would go it's not just
killing people it's a hook you gotta
listen me it's hot I'm gonna get it so
smart and brave start with Lisa Lisa I
think you even said it in your own
pictures like they're both this they're
both that they're too similar you're
pairing likes a great matchup does it
though what because I'm like you know
lay the weapon and predator where the
end fight I feel like we'd be over like
that because of predator and his ability
I feel like bond and hunt at least
they're neck-and-neck
it's like watching like smooth peanut
butter fight chunky peanut butter it's
like the same versus the same - like the
accent they're both smooth they're both
good fighters they both have like the
SkyMall catalog full of gadgets it's
like it's it's you know one A and one B
and it's just not that interesting to me
Lethal Weapon is insane I mean vs.
predator is insane I'm kind of I'm you
kind of sold me on it but the the gently
fight was good that was like grumpy old
men versus
like just getting their ass kicked over
and over again lately with a predator
days days not as fight scene that's like
a that's a smash cut to both of their
heads cut off the predator hunts the
most dangerous prey in the world not
like to one suicidal guy that's probably
gonna broke blow his brains out anyways
with the Predators they're not and one
leg out of shape kind of family man who
doesn't really who yeah and yes so
you're saying an out-of-shape
like divorced guy wouldn't be a match
for like a team of terrorists sir or
like maybe like a paleontologists who
were there to vet an island would
probably get killed immediately by
dinosaur that's too much of an underdog
like you still have to buy into like
Danny Glover could old Danny Glover yes
the weapons for Danny Glover it would
come up in Ford a clever not that not
predator to Daniel ever maybe believe
the weapon forties like on it yes pills
he's like that's what scary scary that's
what adds snakes the problem with lethal
weapon for is that ultimately that movie
wasn't focused on them no Chris Rock and
yeah they're trying to so why don't you
like Marvel Zombies or this one let's do
that well I like them both and I would
pay to see a Mission Impossible James
Bond movie not as quick as I pay in it
you see a perfect Lethal Weapon vs.
predator Lethal Weapon versus anything
but as he said chunky peanut butter
smooth peanut butter I disagree so I'm
gonna tell you guys why I think your
movies not our bad ideas yours won't
work
yours flat won't work the current tone
of the Marvel movies is not built to do
Roger Kirkman's Robert Kirkman's Roger
that's my friend oh god I hope he's not
watching Robert Kirkman's Marvel Zombies
succeeded because of an Ultimate Marvel
storyline involving the Fantastic Four
and it's cynic allottee and anger
towards its content you think which
we're gonna need to get to sooner or
later this is the Marvel alternate
Cinematic Universe that whatever you do
all these pin off things this is like
phase 5 or 6 when we're all sick of this
is like when there aren't movies anymore
sooner than you think
I'm more an alternate Marvel Cinematic
Universe during all of the a-list actors
it's totally inconsistent the reason the
comics work is because the Marvel comics
aren't totally consistent with each
other x-men is often much darker than
anything that happens in spider-man
spider-man is usually darker than
anything that happens in like Miss
Marvel these comics work because they
cater different audiences the Marvel
Universe movies I just got mad Marvel
Universe movies the if you asked me and
no one has but if you ask me the big
problem with the movies is they are two
totally consistent Avengers two was just
like Avengers one again and then someone
got killed and there was blood the only
one of them that had even a vaguely
different tone is the original Iron Man
and it's what allowed them to kick it
off the movies have different subject
matter but they're all pg-13 I feel like
events going up against aliens I mean
they've got God's in specific I know but
me coming just from the movie side of
things like I can't imagine zombies
within the world of the current movie
well the problem you're complaining that
they're in like a parody because the
comic is a parody yeah well Marvel
Zombies is a silly super dark incredibly
violent really unpleasant to read not
for everyone and not for everyone movie
and I just wrote American altro which
came out as a super violent not for
everyone movie but I would never pin the
Marvel characters and that would be like
boom well your complaint is that they're
all getting to say me and consistent
from each other and then saying that
this is the problem with this that it's
too different I mean this is a breath of
fresh you know oh yeah a breath of fresh
air would also be starting a Marvel
movie with Captain with like Chris Evans
jerking off imagine it's it's it's a
cool idea
I like Marvel Zombies but at the end of
the day it doesn't match with what we
have and I thought our job was to match
the things we have good that's a good
point I don't want to leash in this too
so thoughts on either their pictures why
they don't work yeah well I just I love
the lethal weapon movies I just would
love to see them do another one and not
do something weird with predator in
there just because I can't imagine the
and it's a cool idea
I like there you
wisecracking about the whole situation
but it's just when it comes down to the
final fight I just feel like it'd be
over like that
but humans have repeatedly defeated
Paris loved her defeated predator nude
and not physically he just trapped and
that's never but yeah and I disagree
that two characters who are evenly
matched is not exciting to watch on
screen because I feel like that is that
that's what creates the tension it's
like who's gonna win who will beat out
each other and to see them go
head-to-head
I love these spy movies and to see those
two characters like that gets me really
excited I'm not interested in seeing
white men in their late forties fight to
save the world anymore right now
and I'm not even saying like white men
like Oh sis white privilege like
honestly I don't want to see Tom Cruise
I like the idea of Mission Impossible
versus James Bond but in its current I
hated rogue nation really I do that it
really bought it made me tired and
sleepy I thought it's it well like she's
fine it just when you when you're coming
off of Mission Impossible 4 which is an
awesome cartoon that's funny and
self-aware this was not that this if he
gets in a motorcycle accident I'm never
this guy so wait no don't I want to get
this track I gotta keep a certain point
Mission Impossible visa side why it why
and it for both of you why is this not
right I've heard chunky peanut butter
versus regular because it's to see me
that's where you guys are standing it
just feels like you know the parents
late having the kids hang out because
they're the same age like you like spy
stuff right you like spy stuff let's
just put them together and make them do
spy things yeah they're evenly matched
true but you want people to be eat
evenly-matched like brains versus brawn
or like fire powers versus I ice powers
like yeah at the most basic level this
is a spot this is five versus five a spy
versus spy movie would be awful you know
they tried I read a script that was
terrible listen listen you're right but
now in every movie ethan hunt ends up
having to go on the run was about he's
been disabled disavowed what if the
person who was sent to track him down
that's like a fun matchup was like the
guarded killer for what a suave guy my
debate for yours they both took you out
because you're he's right
yours is crazy but they're also right
yours is crazy because there's you old
if you'd gone younger perry therefore
new for your place yep you would stuck
in because i do kind of want to see it
but the base of the arguments story of
my life dan sorry any clean up there so
much
this seems ticky-tacky at this point it
is it would be feasible to have joe
pesci on America Online in 1996 it was
available at home so that's not and yeah
I was just if the movie was in 1996
predator - was in 1990 so Danny Glover
wasn't that much older in 96 and he was
in 1990 so yeah yeah things that was it
that was tough so this I love this this
is great let's go to round 2
we missed talking about this last week
because we aired our Chicago Comicon
episode but too important to not talk
about especially since our guest max is
writing a new Superman comic called
Superman American alien comes out
November correct yes please please
please go buy it
yes it's been a lifelong dream of mine
to write a super Superman comic and it
just means the absolute world to me
thank you and it's it's the fulfillment
of a lifelong dream the first issue is
sort of a pretty basic Smallville issue
but then we get less and less basic and
you know I'm not doing anything crazy
with the character but I'm also not
doing anything crazy with the character
so I think I think if you like Superman
or if you don't even like Superman but I
want to like him it's gonna be a good
comic term I'm excited this would be fun
so in honor I know fans so this made
sense because the rumors were George
Miller was a direct Man of Steel - and
now the rumor came out he's not gonna do
it whatever they're doing here's our
chance let's pitch the ultimate Man of
Steel - movie and so this time we're
staying with you Alicia go back to max
and then Spencer but Alicia pitch us
your ultimate Man of Steel - movie which
would likely come out after Batman V
Superman ish yes so wait so does our
pitch have to incorporate the things
that happened in Batman vs Superman it's
it's Man of Steel - and that one's
coming up I would think of me but I
haven't I haven't seen it so should we
should be forced the rule should be okay
take whatever you want but it has to be
a direct sequel to the first Man of
Steel correct and we now know that
Batman's in there we don't know how he's
in a real film I hate okay I'm very
excited can be in the world because we
know Batman is gonna go against Superman
whether you use it or not
that's where just make sure we're the
Justice League is clearly gonna form at
some point in this universe
oh we should go ahead well and I think
like the Marvel Cinematic Universe does
the sequel will kind of be of its own
thing and and you know separate from
Batman vs Superman starting well Alicia
so a Man of Steel - for the man who has
everything based on the 1985 comic of
the same name
I found this comic storyline really
interesting what happens is Superman
he's on planet Krypton and he goes under
the trance of an A
plant called black mercy which shows the
victim what his true heart desires and
what his true heart desires is not to
save planet Earth is not to be with Lois
Lane but to be on Krypton as kal-el with
a family so he has all these illusions
and then he sees his son and then he
eventually realizes it's illusion he has
to tell his son but it's not real it's a
great episode of Justice League two
animated series yeah yeah yeah so it's
it's a dark look and I like darker
character moments with these superhero
films and to direct it I was thinking a
director who I'd love to see do more is
bong joon-ho from snowpiercer haunted
yeah the hosts as well and so he has a
great dark sensibility when it comes to
horror but also as he showed with
snowpiercer he does incredible action
sequences I would love to see him get a
chance to tackle something like this and
I think it could be something different
from the first Man of Steel which I also
didn't like awesome Maxim excited let's
hear it can I think of it for five
seconds sure I told you first I need two
pictures a director but we'll go to
Spencer first all right cool
Man of Steel 2 for me is gonna be like a
real back to basics just Superman versus
Lex Luthor story and I feel like we
didn't get that in Man of Steel 1 we're
not going to get it in Batman versus
Superman because there's too many other
things happening so this is inspired by
Grant Morrison's all-star Superman the
inbrief the plot is lex luthor tricks
her man into the sun or something like
that and he has a year to live and in a
nice twist Lex Luthor is found out of
the plot and he's sentenced to death so
it's both of these Titanic figures
facing their own mortality in like and
you see how they respond differently to
that Superman responds by wanting to
leave a legacy and you know kind of
doing this bucket list and saving people
and trying to solve sick children and
world hunger and trying to do all these
good things that we didn't get to see
Superman do in Man of Steel and Lex
Luthor uses his impending doom to plan
like one last big world-conquering
hurrah and you know it's just these two
is not like a justice leaving diet
do you want me to spoil it the comic
because it's amazing comic that everyone
should read that's Superman comic ever
read cool yeah right
and then the so Superman dies the lex
luthor learns some things or two in the
process and basically reincarnates him
through DNA lex luthor learns they need
Superman to be who he is it's kind of a
Batman Joker thing going on at the end
but you get the good Americana like this
God and confronting his own mortality
and being such a it's like a humble and
giving character that he wasn't in Man
of Steel in in this comic and there's no
there's no Justice League there's no
Juggalo Squad there's no whatever it's
just it's a Superman and Lex Luthor you
know brains and evilness versus brawn
and integrity and that's what I want out
of a Superman movie and I know he
doesn't want to do this but I'm gonna
drag him kicking and screaming is Steven
Spielberg cuz he loves Americana and
Wonder and hope and he can direct big
action okay got it great no pressure
those are two good ones in the wake of
destruction of over half of Metropolis
at the end of Man of Steel Superman is a
universally reviled figure Clark Kent a
small-town boy who had never even been
in a fistfight before he was attacked by
a military man and forced the decimated
City he loved has terrible PTSD and has
given up being Superman he gets the
shakes every night he's trying to date
Lois Lane but the fact that he has a
secret that she is doing a huge piece on
that she is being like very revolve
about the idea that Superman was
ultimately a negative thing and that the
destruction you know it's 9/11 it's it's
ten 911s the the destruction of Man of
Steel
the fact that in the trailers for Batman
no no Batman versus Batman vs Superman
is doesn't exist Batman vs Superman
doesn't exist okay so this is a direct
sequel to Man of Steel Clark moves home
he is miserable but he has to do one
more assignment before he leaves his job
at the Daily Planet and we get to really
see this guy I mean he's living in New
York post 9/11 basically everyone on the
street has graffiti saying like
Superman's [ __ ] incredible
Superman [ __ ] sucks you know like
everyone also doesn't understand because
it's the age of the Internet that
Superman and Zod or even necessarily
to different people like they sort of
think they both came to earth at the
same time and did the same thing keep in
mind the first time the world saw that
Superman suit was [ __ ] hip is
throwing the city so for all they know
they were just two random aliens and
that haunts Clark every night because he
thinks of himself as a man and as an
American and is a good guy and that
tortures him he has to do one more thing
he has to go interview this billionaire
investor named Lex Luthor he goes to
interview him he doesn't understand why
he's been chosen he's a rookie
interviewer and Lex it's a noun and goes
you and me have the same problem but we
have an image problem
he's like why now everybody knows Lex
Luthor it's a Sharky investor he treats
his employees like [ __ ] he's basically
an evil Elon Musk but when you're
sitting there with him and he's Tom
Hanks he seems kind of great he's like -
Henry Cavill like you know you and I
have an image problem
he's like I'm just a reporter he goes no
you're not you're Superman you think it
was hard for me to figure out who you
were but there's an opportunity here for
both of us to work together I think I
can repair your image we're gonna start
branding you but I need you to do favors
for me I need you to repair facilities
around the world I think I can make you
look like the greatest humanitarian
figure of all time now is that what you
want to do do you want to help people
and inspire people with hope he's like
yes so it starts and suddenly we're
getting into all the stuff that we
didn't get to see in Man of Steel him
saving people him being sent places Lex
Luthor is sponsoring Superman it's
incredible he suddenly has a 60 Minutes
interview everyone starts to love
Superman like they do in the comics and
understand that what happened in
Metropolis was a mistake that's when
someone breaks into Clark's home it's a
guy in a bat costume you need to listen
to me you can't trust Luthor what are
you talking about you've broken into my
home you're you're the Batman you're the
vigilante from Gotham that's right
listen it's part of a bigger plan he has
bad bad intentions but if you listen to
me I can help you out of this if you
work for me
instead of Luthor as an agent of Batman
we can pull together the Earth's
greatest heroes what are you talking
about the Earth's greatest heroes you're
talking about all the other freaks that
showing up you're an alien your birth
certificate is forged I know everything
about you you need to start listening to
me now Luther security tips there's
someone in here [ __ ] knocks down
Batman rips his mask off it's Bruce
Wayne
basically it's Bill Gates he escapes
Luthor's guys arrived who was here it
was the bat vigilante did you see his
face could you figure out who he was
no we then entered the bulk of the movie
which is Luthor forcing Superman to
track down and capture the members of
the Justice League all the other
metahumans and they seem scary the
Flash's powers are out of control
Wonder Woman kills lots of people Green
Arrow is another friggin vigilante the
Martian Manhunter is a monster and by
the time you get to the third act he has
captured all of them and that's when
Luthor reveals what you've created is a
sovereign force more powerful than any
that has ever existed on earth this team
could take down any army no nation in
the world could stand against us you
have given me a black water that I can
take over the world with how does that
feel you [ __ ] idiot and Superman is
like I thought we were doing this to
protect the world
I'm not even sweet he's like your next
job is to take out Batman
and he's like okay so he goes to take
off back take out Batman because Luthor
is still sort of on his side even though
he's getting scarier and scarier he
still saved Clark Lex Luthor has saved
Superman from being a pariah and as
things grow an emotional intensity came
mine I'm making this up as I go along as
things grow in emotional intensity by
the end of the last act Superman with
Batman goes rogue because Bruce Wayne
basically says you didn't give away my
identity I know you know there's
something wrong with Luthor if you want
to inspire people do what I do inspire
by fear scare Luthor because that's what
he's making you do and Superman realizes
I don't need to beat Lex Luthor
I can't condemn him I can't testify on a
stand I can't say Who I am what I need
to do is free the Justice League so the
last act of the movie is Batman Superman
team-up I don't [ __ ] work for you
we're gonna work together I don't find
I'm not an agent of Batman they free the
Justice League have to fight Luthor and
in one of the coolest sequences in movie
history beautifully beautifully directed
by James Cameron I'm pulling them off
avatar thank you the Justice League
Justice League gets into a major fight
in a city center with Luthor's Luthor
droids like the robots except the whole
time Superman Clark is like those people
we gotta say these people so one member
of the Justice League is fighting the
Luthor joins at a time
there is almost no property damage and
no one is hurt and at the end of it
Superman lands and rips open the Luthor
Droid and Luthor's like you kill me on
TV
fine I'm the Justice League is like
walking up behind him oh [ __ ] big knocks
him out Justice League now exists Man of
Steel three I would want to focus on
doomsday Justice League guys what do you
think I want to say that the team-up yes
that's hard for me to poke holes I think
both at the movies sound really great
the only thing I would say is I don't
really want to see Steven Spielberg do a
Superman movie I'd love to see him
continue do war films with Tom Hanks
forever Spencer
well I think with Alisha's you gave me
more of my least favorite part of
Manistee which was Krypton it's a lot of
the Crypt up though don't like weird
like paint art robots and then like you
should give that another pass and max
that was amazing it started off really
dark though with pea twists I don't want
to see Superman with PTSD like I don't
want to see mopey Superman nope there we
go
and just even though that sounds awesome
like I don't want to see him being
manipulated into doing good I want him
to do good out of his own volition and
just be the Superman himself just once
without luthor manipulating him and I
think we still haven't seen that no we
haven't and we still haven't seen just a
Superman movie I mean we got one but we
still haven't seen which movie really
good one yeah we still been seeing the
one we want out of Henry Cavill in this
new era yeah
again yours your sons awesome but it
frozen the Justice League and it throws
in Batman in really smart ways I just
want a Superman Lex Luthor movie I just
want that so would yours have the
aftermath of Man of Steel because I feel
like that needs to be addressed because
it was ridiculous and that's the only
thing I liked about well one of the
things I like about Batman vs Superman
is that they look like the damned right
I think that's a mistake in that member
I don't think at any point Zack Snyder
was like this is horrible
I think he was like look at how cool see
how I know that yeah because at the end
they're standing in rubble and they make
out yep and it's like but I think now
he's friend of ya know now he's doing it
well that's what I was doing what to
answer your question to answer your
query about mine or the darkness that
darkness is important because I never
have written I'm writing a Superman come
for DC right now I would never write
this guy this is a boring character it's
a guy in a suit who can fly the most
interesting thing about Superman is that
he's a guy with a job who is nice and
kind and what would I hit administers
that killed his dad the whole point of
Superman is that he wants to do nice
things because he was raised good and
he's a nice guy that's what makes him
cooler than Batman but to answer to
answer your query you talked about him
being manipulated into doing good I
think that's where you have to start as
a sequel to Man of Steel I think you
have to start with a guy who saw city
destroyed and when I don't want to do
this anymore I can't do this right now
and then finds his way to happiness yeah
and I and I like the idea of mine
because I like the idea of him being
conflicted between what he really wants
which is just to be a guy normal guy
with a family versus like having to save
the world and being with Lois Lane
well okay go ahead because I just think
you both sort of kid that was the best
argument of Man of Steel because the
question was made of steel I feel like
your shoes are interesting standalone
stories yes but I think he made the
argument that and he said it and it's
that was the best version that he
pitched coming off of where they wore
was yours too is in these other nether
zones but which could be interesting
given the point too much ask Dan any
things you'd like to add on that round
you know no I mean you know that was
listening to the pitch the only good
pitch yeah the only thing that I found
that was interesting was just that
Alicia's story which I didn't know for
the manners everything was done by Alan
Moore and Dave Gibbons who did Watchmen
which is kind of an interesting little
side note but no I agree I want to see
yours I want to see both of them
actually but I think based again I guess
gave him extra points he did on the fly
and there was some things you probably
could he could have fine-tuned I'm sure
you all I'm thinking is all the things I
would change but still massive props are
doing on the fly so I give you extra
points and I wanted to let's get us
around three round three there's been a
lot of castings for biopics recently
some Kate Blanchet we just casted
Lucille Ball Mike Epps is gonna be
Richard Pryor Josh GAD is gonna be Roger
Ebert just lots of fun castings
happening and so Jordan Campbell soupy
doopy on Twitter asked us if that's the
ultimate biopic movie we're looking for
an actor and what real-life person they
would play and max were to come to you
first this time what was my answer who
was you had said Donald Trump I really I
mean I really like the George Bush
biopic with Berlin
it was Berlin right yeah yeah and and I
really feel like Donald Trump is a
massively corrupt unbelievably terrible
really shockingly bad person and the
more you research him the more things
you find out that are just like
what the more insane stories you hear
the guy announced that he would [ __ ] his
own daughter if she wasn't his daughter
that's a real quote it's not direct but
he says if she wasn't my daughter I'd
probably be dating her that's a real
quote he's a monster he's an animal he
was born into wealth and never went down
he's done nothing but lose money while
accruing idiots he lies to everyone he
says whatever is on his mind it's an
incredibly I so couldn't get him to
tweet you or reply after this hey Donald
hey Donald your piece of [ __ ] they're
never gonna be President and if you are
at the end of our country no I really I
think I I think I think you know his
lack of restraint his misunderstanding
his level of privilege could be in a
biopic with the right director in the
right actor so why Will Ferrel because I
think it'd be funny but I bet they're so
into comedy it's not a comedy his life
is a [ __ ] tragedy so try to figure
out Will Ferrell's playing the legit
strategy and comedy are so
interconnected I mean with social
network of comedy no but it sure was
funny you know it's it's it's one of
those things where that story of this
animal who basically does whatever he
wants and never compromises his whole
life and is rewarded and rewarded and
rewarded by a sick society that favors
capitalism over compassion and favors
volume over content this is a terrible
person who is one is a massively rich
and is not a legit candidate for
president there is so much to unpack
here that that movie incredible I like
the passion but what you're focusing on
what era up to now haul away okay weirdo
thing all right from set up coke head to
corrupt coke head billionaire to corrupt
coke head Hotel and Casino proprietor to
corrupt coke head presidential candidate
the whole way he's an animal and it
would be [ __ ] great maybe not well
Ferrell may be fast binder but everyone
cast Fassbender is everything in
everything but it's a media role for
Ferrell we'll keep it there and Lady
role for only comeback Spencer but
you're right role pure class for well
good I am going with Nick Offerman as
Teddy Roosevelt not just because they
look the same these are two guys who
have both written books on the virtues
of masculinity and what it is to be a
man and they both look identical I mean
and Teddy Roosevelt has this awesome
duality to him where he's basically fat
Batman he was he was born like this
sickly weak child two rich parents and
he basically trained himself into a
badass he apprenticed himself out in a
dude ranch he he sent himself to war
when he really didn't need to go he's
leading all these suicidal charges and
he's a really compelling character but
there's kind of a darkness cuz you're
worried like oh I don't really want to
see this guy being president because
he's kind of a war monger and kind of
like a gung-ho shoot him up kind of
character but in like a nice twist he
does mellow out when he becomes
president and he becomes a gigantic
conservationist and he wins the Nobel
Peace Prize and he's just got this
amazing character arc from from cowboy
well from rich brat who has asthma and
can't go outside - like gung-ho cowboy -
war hero - war monger - one of the best
five presidents we've ever had and Nick
Offerman looks just like him he does
look like him Alicia what's your pick
I'm going with Cary Grant
played by George Clooney there's
something really fascinating to me about
classic movie stars because we didn't
know as much about them as we do with
stars today with social media and
tabloids and team at shows paparazzi etc
etc and Cary Grant is always so
interesting he's had a fascinating life
IQ he was born as Alec Archibald Leitch
in England he moved to Hollywood he
changed his name then of course he was
involved with so many great classic
movies so and a biopic you could get the
filming of like North by Northwest and
he's go Friday an affair to remember all
his great movies George Clooney modeled
himself after Cary Grant - the very
suave debonair classy gentleman romantic
icon but Cary Grant also of course had a
lot of rumors about bisexuality whose
body he had a relationship with Randolph
Scott and was living with him and there
was at
photoshoot they both did together that
was really sweet so there's just such an
interesting layer plus he did a lot of
LSD yeah a lot of LSD under doctor's
supervision because he suffered from
depression and they used that to help
him with his depression so much
interesting stuff that could be dealt
into here and for me just that whole era
and Hollywood is so fascinating so I'd
love to see it great free for all what
do you guys think of each other's pics
I think I want to see all three of these
movies but I think mine's the most
entertaining well I say this with great
sincere fear but his story's not over
yet she's still going wait until we know
how this all shakes out because this
could be the difference between comedy
and tragedy is seeing what out what the
next four years of his life it's almost
hard to watch now it's so close to it
absolutely it's the definition of too
soon and then I think that he should
play himself he is like an actor he's a
fake I don't the reason I'm not so
disgusted by him is because I don't
believe the things that he's saying I
don't think he believes them either I'm
like you're a fraud you're you're like a
goof no you're thinking of Glenn Beck
don't Donald Trump is completely
transparent to the degree that he can't
control anything he does saying that
that she was questioning him because she
was bleeding out of somewhere he no no
this is not a man who is fake
Donald Trump has been congratulated and
rewarded for expressing himself and
being honest but do you think his point
is it a little early do you want to see
where it goes no of course not the movie
the movie end you know it's do is see
the movie ends with I am announcing my
candidacy for president of the United
States and you going o ending you know
animal it's it's more interesting Teddy
Roosevelt's inspiring figure Cary Grant
is possibly my favorite celebrity of all
time and and the LSD component of that
is in Crimea
I wanna see [ __ ] Donald Trump I want
to go see it he's too interesting he's
too interesting okay
thoughts oh yeah and again we're
question shoot don't each others too
Teddy Roosevelt that's yeah it sounds
interesting I just I guess for me is not
that much of a fascinating figure
because you don't know enough yeah yeah
I don't know much about him and also
compelled to see it but George Clooney's
to or mind well yeah I would have the
young active play of a younger version
of Cary Grant but the older version
George Clooney ever done a British
accent it's like a little but at the
beginning I guess you back out of it
because he's not playing Carrie Barry
there's a train what's called the
transatlantic that's weird coming out of
George Clooney's mouth to me that's just
yeah I agree with what Spencer is saying
idea is bad maybe I think your idea is
bad what about oh I just you know I
think I I don't have much cuz it yet it
seems entertaining I can't get a sense
of the tone it could be played as a
farce or it could be Pony Brothers as a
terrible okay I don't know if Will
Ferrell has the chops I liked I don't
like I wish I hadn't chosen that like
weird voice upper movie it was fine but
he I think he's gonna be too funny
you're gonna be wanting a change later
Caprio the campaign will Sarah which was
which is a comedy I'm gonna call I think
I think you're there right the casting
was was wrong yeah so I'm just gonna
hang out if you're my you might be out
this round out of these two which one do
you like just because I'm trying to get
everyone's final thoughts here yeah we
have to include the casting if it's
we're cluding the casting and everything
that they've brought is it Nick Offerman
as if we're including the casting which
I wish we weren't because I can't go or
no one as fighter I mean George Clooney
is
is too old to to do even like North by
Northwest Kari grant visually for me he
might be the same age roughly so if I
had to pick between theirs I would pick
mine I think I got all your takes all
right calling this one Dan before I call
it anything you'd like to add so many
things I could fact check
I can't fact check Donald Trump's drug
use unfortunately I can't put I can't
put the data's daughter thing in
perspective which is that they asked him
they asked him what he would think if
his daughter posed for Playboy and he
said that he didn't think that she would
do it but he said she does have a nice
figure I've said that if it [ __ ]
weren't my daughter perhaps I would be
dating her see this movie asking is that
horrible yes we want to watch that movie
but I don't know if the casting was sold
I think we want to learn more about and
nick offerman deserves a role smudger
gets the point it's anyone's game Nick
God Nick offers the nicest view the
coolest dude I want to see Nick Offerman
view or rav4 alright I think we're gonna
be crazy
Jack Reacher to was announced for the
fall I'm not sure if that was the sequel
everyone was super dying for but
whatever they're making it so Brian
moody for the third moody 39:59 on
Twitter asked us what standalone action
film most deserves a sequel so if we
could pick any one that never got it so
sequel or what will we take or how do we
do it right and we're gonna start this
time with Alicia wood for me John wick
was a really nice surprise getting to
see ya yeah it's getting a sequel but
that's all count it yeah so yeah so I'm
pitching that that would be perfect for
a sequel because first laughs it was a
surprise hit it was made for twenty
million dollars made 80 million
worldwide it also had a really simple
premise you know kill the cute dog bad
Eastern European guys you will die so
you the possibilities for a sequel
endless story wise plus I think it also
had an interesting mythology that Hall
hotel that they go to where they have a
different currency and different rules
and I want to see more of that world
explored plus Keanu Reeves doing all the
head shots the cool action had great
style yeah I'm thinking I'm back I want
to see more of John wick so he's back in
action okay Spencer what's yours I'm
going with the rock to rock harder
[Laughter]
michael bay's the rock this is a movie
that for some reason didn't get a sequel
probably well for any number of reasons
but I think that they left the door open
Nick Cage was still alive Sean Connery
goes off in the distance he's got a
microfilm with all the FBI's like the
NCIS deepest secrets on it and now Nick
Cage is a wanted criminal basically cuz
he let the most wanted fugitive go and
he has all the secrets in the world in
this little microfilm so he gets caught
he gets thrown to Gitmo the modern rock
you know in Guantanamo Bay Cuba which is
where Sean Connery happens to be hiding
out so Sean Connery gets himself
captured gets himself placed in the same
cell and when do you see this movie
coming out right now but like a couple
years ago but it's a it's happening
right now and you know of course they're
in there with a bunch of the most wanted
terrorists and some guys who shouldn't
be there who they that kind of con air
it's kind of con era Sh thank you Andy
it's kind of con era shove those
character on country coming out of
retirement to do this movie a return to
form for Michael Bay and then breaking
out of Guantanamo Bay prison Wow okay
max what's your take great standalone
action movies that I would want to see
sequels to The Matrix Pirates of the
Caribbean
I would love a third Terminator movie
because we're so good yeah big one well
then let's go ahead and do one that I
really feel would have the most
relevance and be the best which is
probably the Last Starfighter The Last
Starfighter focused if you haven't seen
it The Last Starfighter in the foe in
the 80s focused on the idea that an
arcade game when which you flew a
spaceship was actually being used as a
recruitment tool for an alien race who
needed someone to come save them and of
course the person who got sent to save
them was a teenager now with video game
technology the way it is with immersive
game technology the way it is the idea
of this
is huge I think doing a sequel not a
reboot a sequel involving those
characters and then bringing in a new
crop of like basically gamers but you
know the issue is what is even a gamer
anymore
everybody plays video games I mean your
cell phone is a [ __ ] video game in
its own way everything is based on
instant response and you could do
something there hasn't been in a while
which is a really cool dogfight space
movie fun dog fights in space well at
the same time doing a really sweet
Ghostbuster II été character comedy
within it which is what the original
last starfighter is and I think that is
a [ __ ] awesome idea and I think if
you announce that via like a marketing
campaign where you play the game you
know like it's a free download app oh my
god the people who are the best at this
app are being abducted by aliens you
know there's almost no good movies about
video games there aren't but there is
one and it's called The Last Starfighter
good thoughts guys free for all pretty
girls it sounds like pixels people like
a group of friends being recruited who
are the best at their video games to go
take on the okay so they share a premise
no dude matrix in Dark City basically
say move necromancer but anyways the the
pixels last starfighter I don't know
what that voice was that was me being
like guy discussing movie in the
background in New York do we suck yeah
I've kind of given up on video game
movies I love video games I wanted to
succeed but there seems to be something
inherent in gamers it's because it's a
great it's a great it's a great it's a
great movie a lot of star fighter and I
want to make a sequel to that movie that
happens to be about video games
you know they advertised American ultra
as a STONER movie it's not a STONER
movie it's an action movie that has
stoners in it the problems with your
ideas is number one Sean Connery has
been out of action as an actor to bring
back he has very a senile dementia and
it's too old
Michael Bay Michael Bay has not
delivered us a good movie in 26 the raw
what an opportunity for him to make a
comeback okay and one last problem a big
problem here Rock harder yeah like a
really cool trailer for The Last
Starfighter is so much more exciting to
me more exciting to me than another
sequel to a movie from the 90s and what
was John linka already has a sequel so
it's cheating I mean it's it's you
should have to pick a new one because
it's not fair to you well gosh it's so
hard on cable I think you're insisting
on it being a sequel is a mistake it
should be a reboot because no one alive
cares about that movie I mean not as
many people do that you're right dude
Mad Max why would you ever make a sequel
to Mad Max you should just make a [ __ ]
reboot why didn't we reboot Mad Max and
it turns out what it did
I mean Mad Max has no continuity what's
the continuity from I don't remember how
the last starfighter ended I think he's
headed back so then so video games being
recruitment tools are just like a known
factor on earth now no they never it's
all secret dude he gets abducted in
secret he goes and saves everybody comes
home a different game it would start
with the same guy being contacted by the
aliens and being like we're having
trouble well no no they would it would
also have the thing where there's like
an arcade machine and the kids are like
you know the like fifteen-year-old kids
are like what the [ __ ] is this
well they stole a Starfighter for the
first time just about a year ago how
does it have what's ovarian and and I
really enjoyed it yeah it comes back
he's a big hero but it's not a big
you're on earth no he just has new
confidence yeah because it's a team but
I always said I want to see a reboot of
just because I like that premise and I
like that storyline
there's so much that could be done with
it that would appeal to a younger
audience today you're saying over six oh
yeah well I think it's a reboot to
reboot Paul he's in it well sort of it's
he's in it as obi-wan and then there's a
new crop of three a girl a you know
another guy and then a guy and they they
are raid on their iPhone maybe two girls
and or you know it's you wants the
advertising the opportunity of doing
people are good at video games your life
isn't sad your life the people who are
trolling you and being a piece of [ __ ]
to you their lives are sad it's like
you're hearing you're a [ __ ] hero in
real life and that final statement
quickly why the other two don't work
spend everything I said I don't have
anything else say my last art fair the
John wick I feel like it kind of blew
its wad we have the surprises over of
seeing Keanu be a badass and headshot
all these sounds like taken - written
all over it like we're gonna up the
anywhere what are they gonna cow you
just punch her in it's like Keanu he's
back John wick is back he's chatting
with people it's still dark new dog I
just think the beautiful thing about
John wick it was a cool movie but it was
the surprise of it and the other thing
like this movie came out of nowhere
Wow Keanu Reeves is a badass oh my god
they killed a dog and same thing with
taking of Liam Neeson wow this guy is a
bass and then taken - it's like writing
itself for the whole movie then the
surprise wouldn't have worked like it
would basically like oh cool he's
kicking back but because it had so much
to it it also did it also the cool thing
about John wick is that it didn't
explain itself yeah what's a sequel
might do so your idea is bad
Man of Steel actually yeah John wick is
the wheels are turning on that there's
been talk of a Last Starfighter sequel
but it's always that nebulous like the
original hurry things yeah there's
always talk and then yeah the guy that
starting The Last Starfighter I didn't
know this also played Michael Brody and
jaws the revenge so you know good movie
bad movie we can recast you can recast
no I said this thing is the negative
just a little trivia bit little piece of
trivia for jaws the revenge oh yes Gimli
tough I think I'm gonna take taking the
fact that I'm taking away time which is
what I think you're the biggest argument
in Sears was just cuz I feel like what
stealing mimosas are sequel also that
movie stands perfectly well alone and
doesn't its premise will do my
Starfighter is a whole universe of
characters the rock is to people but
because that movie was so silly and the
thing you pitch is kind of fun just I
think you also just gave me the best
arguments against theirs which I didn't
feel like I got from the other two
people and that's what ultimately put me
over the edge for Spencer to get the
points I wasn't focusing on Spencer's
because I thought it was obviously a bad
as we all know Deadpool is a superhero
getting our right r-rated movie that's
with Shawn Michaels and Twitter pretty
Garba asked us what superhero movie
besides Deadpool would you like to see
an r-rated movie now it can be an
existing or someone we've never seen
before anybody is fair game here and
Spencer is it's your turn I just give me
a quick pitch who are you picking I
can't believe I won for rock to rock
hard
[Laughter]
I want an r-rated Doctor Doom movie
clearly we can't do Fantastic Four right
so let's switch it up let's get our
first movie from the villains
perspective and this is like superhero
Scarface this is a this is a bad guys
rising to power but there are redeemable
qualities about him I don't want to get
into doctor dooms whole backstory here
but he starts he always has a good
reason from his perspective for
everything he's doing which is what
makes a great villain and what makes him
sympathetic so he's you know he's the
kind of guy that conquers the world and
then gives it up because he there's no
challenge anymore
he he is a dictator but he solves world
hunger and poverty and then I love the
idea of having a villain movie a
superhero movie where the Fantastic Four
just kind of on the periphery like they
just you know he runs across Reed
Richards in college doesn't make a huge
impression he always has his own agenda
and these people are just kind of pest
getting in his way that I think has not
been done before and be the details of a
story are so horrific that I think you
need an r-rating to tell it max it's
your turn why the [ __ ] do people keep
trying to make Fantastic Four dark I
don't know us like I don't understand I
don't understand sorry
that's nothing against you but no
there's a character named moon Knight
who's a Marvel character who struggles
with schizophrenia isn't sure if the
Egyptian gods communicating with him
telling him to be a superhero are real
and yet goes out there and beats the
living [ __ ] out of people in the most
violent way possible because he's told
to buy voices in his head I feel like
the opportunity here is huge and I'm not
gonna pitch you specifics if you just
Google Moon Knight you'll see that my
argument should win this one it's a
character that is not exploited enough
by Marvel he is essentially a darker
alternative to daredevil and spider-man
you know you have a bunch of guys in New
York right you got daredevil Luke Cage
iron fist
spider-man Punisher yeah I can just keep
going and going the sleepwalker I
believe lives in New York I love
and so you have to trust me when I say a
moon night movie don't r-rated in the
tone of a Fincher movie of a guy who
starts hearing a voice that says poem an
ancient Egyptian god you have been
chosen and yet has already been
diagnosed with schizophrenia and yet
this voice seems realer his personal
life is falling apart
but by god he's gonna find his sanity
he's gonna [ __ ] make himself it's an
origin movie that plays like a thriller
because it's a dude I mean he's not even
in the moon that caused him to like more
than halfway through the movie and you
do a really cool reinvention of the Moon
Knight costume that looks like the moon
knight costume because the best thing
about having a crazy superhero is when
they're in the suit they can look crazy
I despise dark the I despise most dark
superhero stuff I think dark Shapira
stuff the exception to the rule or why
it's become popular because it's the
most basic thing you can do with
superheroes is do the dark version make
them zombies
Batman's old now what if Batman killed
someone and all you do when you do that
because everyone's pitching want you
every [ __ ] can you talk to in a
comput story is like what if Superman
raped someone like that you're like it's
been done have you read the boys have
you read powers it's been done better
than you could do it's been done better
than I can do it Watchmen it's the most
basic thing you can do what's compelling
and what needs an r-rating about
midnight that makes it different from
these other superhero things is that the
character is dealing with an adult issue
he is dealing with mental illness and
that is captivating that is compelling
and seeing that as a superhero and at
the end still the Espace / a tional he
overcomes it [ __ ] awesome got it I
like that one militia Alicia what's your
pick I'm going with a character you
mentioned max and that character that I
don't feel like has had a proper chance
on the big screen and that's Punisher we
got to punishment movies that haven't
been that great I did really like do you
remember that 2012 like short fan film
dirty laundry yeah well mine I really
liked that that that cool style and
that's what made me personally
interested in that character and we
haven't seen anything like that on the
big screen so this character obviously
lends himself to and our ratings dark
and and
violent plug could this be the same
person from the deck from Netflix that's
coming Oh John Bennett's I mean I I
really like him as as an actor so that
could but I also like the fact that Tom
Hardy has spoken about how he would love
to play Frank Castle and I would love to
see I just Tom Hardy and everything so
yeah I'd love to see that and I just
feel like Punisher needs a better chance
now the rights have gone back to Marvel
Studios too so they have a chance to do
something cool
all right guys Friday's rebuffing you
guys right off the top can you check can
you check something for me absolutely or
both Punisher movies that have already
come out rated are one of them is I know
the Dolph Lundgren was a hard arm
Punisher all 3d Punisher films that have
come out I like two of those Punisher
movies I thought war zone was a lot of
fun I thought the Thomas Jane one was an
interesting thriller that happened what
you love to say kind of shine I don't
want to see any fight like to see them
again I'm interesting with other
characters your idea well he could be
with spider-man Yeah right but I've seen
what I'm saying is you you for the
second time or pitching a movie that
already exists there are three punish
and and I love Punisher I'm there's
nothing against Frank but we've seen it
three times
your idea is makes me insane because
Viktor despite being a really
interesting character does not deserve
his own movie again we have seen three
we have seen Doctor Doom in movies three
times now his story though it's not doom
story he trusts them to make his story I
didn't say who was involved who was
saying and also Doctor Doom what's cool
about him is that he's The Fantasticks
for villain because he's a douche he's
not a carbureted douche I mean he gets
badly [ __ ] up but nothing about the
character Doctor Doom tummy says this
has to be an r-rated movie your idea of
it as a villain Scarface is awesome
but it is not an r-rated movie and
that's what the question was Moon Knight
is so yeah I got noted good good point
so you guys are on the ropes what I
wasn't as familiar with Moon Knight
either so I did have to google him and I
still don't know what he is he's so many
he's got multiple personalities a bunch
of different origin stories he's hearing
voices he has Egyptian powers but he's
also like a martial artist and he he I
can't get my head around the character
and I don't think the pitch like really
solidified who this guy is is he you
want me to pick a movie he wanted to see
right now people I don't know if we have
time I'd like yeah he does the knock on
him was was he's just Batman in white
which he didn't seem like it but then I
was trying to fence so what is he and I
still don't know Aryan Captain America
went to Soldier which kind of spoke a
bit about like it a little Easter egg
dropped in there along with Stephen
strange so he sounds cool he sounds like
you need to do some serious like let's
just stick to one Moon Knight story
because you've been in a lot of
different hands and there's a kind of
different issue on him okay we did we
stuck to it and the movies out the
movies out it's an r-rated mr. robot in
tone
David Fincher II really good action
movie about Moon Knight separate from
all the other characters oh yes he in
the Marvel Universe maybe it is maybe it
isn't
I didn't think we were supposed to say
who was involved I thought we were
supposed to say which character you feel
would do the best and deserves an
r-rated film I think dealing with an
adult issue and an intelligent
compassionate way and turning them into
a [ __ ] superhero is risky fun and has
big opportunities to be a really good
movie I don't get me wrong I love
Punisher and Doctor Doom but they don't
need to be r-rated movies also Moon
Knight cheaper than either of those
movies he is very street-level but he
has cosmic powers but it's a thing you
can do that is after-effects now okay I
can do I can do a really cool Moon
Knight movie in my garage but no one
will see it and it doesn't it won't get
the attention and love
a big scale movement I think is
interesting only when he's where the
Fantastic Four and that feels like we've
done Fantastic Four and I don't think
anyone's gonna go there for a while well
I want my doctor new movie to come out
first and then you can do the like Band
of Brothers letters from iwo jima say
where you see the whole story from the
Fantastic Four's perspective like you
imagine like the last - full movie
didn't happen never happened all right
Dan anything you're gonna add here so
yes I I always think that Thomas J
Morris pg-13 for some reason but no they
were all three punishes we're rated R
and yes sit well does say and Winter
Soldier when he drops the super strange
saying he references that they're having
trouble with the man in Cairo which a
lot of people said because munites
powers just derive from Egyptian gods
yeah no it could also be they could be a
number this is again this is fans kind
of running I have some speculation but
similar you're speculating this could be
a moon night reference maybe not in
descending him up but a reference to
very much switch
I gotta go off the arguments I got off
the arguments sadly he did sort of shoot
you down Alicia sadly it was good but he
didn't snipe me down there and then it
came down to YouTube and I just think
his argument that his pitches were a
little stronger than even on the
unfamiliar I'm not gonna use that
against him so Moon Knight r-rated movie
make more sense to me why don't you do
something like Doctor Doom eats VR is
really where it's got stuck
- with max2 dispenser one for Leisha
leslie she gets this will go to a
three-way tie around six this is a fun
one this is a nice little fun one force
Friday brought us a lot of cool new toys
excited for Star Wars Jack DeFranco at
Jack wagon 85 asked on Twitter what's
the best movie toy now it has to be
specific merchandise from a toy from a
movie I mean max we're starting with you
what was the best movie toy I've
realized that I have an answer but I
don't know if it counts will you tell me
if this counts I know which one you
pitch yeah the ghostbusters firehouse
yes totally counts okay but that was the
animated serie oh yeah sure
okay so when I was a kid the first
stories I told where mice were by myself
in my room
and I would I would sit and I would do
this I would sit and I would imagine
very vividly in my head the the the
story happening and the action figures
ultimately weren't they weren't it
didn't I didn't need to act everything
out with them the way they always show
kids doing in movies and I don't think
anybody does you just hold them and
they're like totems of that character
and they they talk and you see the scene
so clearly but in order to really tell
the good stories you need the good
totems so you need the Donatello who
does this you need the Donatello who
does that you need the [ __ ] Stay Puft
man even if he's way too small and the
Ghostbusters on the totem the totem
exists and you own that character and
it's like having access to a character
and and you suddenly are touching it and
what was great and the reason the III
don't know a lot about toys I don't I
can't name a bunch of toys but the
reason this one stuck out to me so
clearly is because I had the fire house
so all of the adventures since I had the
fire house I could do anything with the
Ghostbusters because I'd always have a
starting point for the story and I think
men and they're in there and like what
if oh okay he-man what are you doing
here you came down to the firehouse it
was a location which it was an inning to
any interior and an exterior and it
didn't matter that there was like a pole
that they could go up and down what
mattered is that I now it's a dollhouse
suddenly you now have a location for all
of your little guys to live and there
were so few location toys I mean they
but like ultimately this [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] look Tommy can turn into all
these gimmicks all the different colors
of Batman they sold after the movie or
the metal suit none of those ultimately
mattered because what you needed was the
most basic toy his arms needed to go up
and down like that if you were lucky
they went in like that not like that and
that was really cool ones or the
spider-man's that have the the sockets
in the legs so he could be compose them
in any different one I remember the
first spider-man toy like that I was
like but like that firehouse was a
beginning for play it was a place for
play to happen it enabled your
imagination it helped you and I loved my
father and good features Alicia what's
your what's your toy going with one for
purely nostalgic reasons the only toy
that I ever collected and that was
mentioned before movie fights The Land
Before Time I had them all you imagine
it was 1988 little leash Malone 7 years
old
convincing her parents to go to Pizza
Hut over and over again even though I
didn't like the food just because I
wanted these toys bargain prices 99
cents each I collected them all I took
them to school I played with them at
lunch time with my friends and I just
have such a love for them even seeing
the picture just makes me so excited so
that for me was forever it will ever
forever be the best movie toy I think
the movie toy is about what you bring to
it and that was just such a special
moment in my life personally so
nostalgic reasons I remember all of
these so far Spencer what are you
picking okay I'm gonna take the
nostalgia goggles off for a second here
and talk about a toy that we would
actually want to play with right now and
that is the bb-8 Star Wars thing that
they just announced that I'm about to
spend a hundred and fifty dollars of my
adult money on that thing is controlled
via your iPhone and it's magic it's it's
just like Star Wars it's a blend of
Technology and magic at the same time
this thing will patrol your house
automatically when you're not there this
thing can be controlled it can do figure
eights I haven't even seen this movie
and this is my
favorite toy that's ever been made I
don't need to see this movie and that's
my favorite toy that's ever been made
you're gonna have a bad time when the
movie comes out and it turns out he's
race yeah I'm so ready to like get this
thing and mess around with it and have
races with other ones and just have and
do this as a full-grown adult and I
think that my favorite toys as a kid
were Ninja Turtles I love to yet chose
I'll I had the limb before time puppets
put that next to me
the bb-8 you transport that back to 1988
and put it next to a Land Before Time
puppet I am like clearing that off the
table and picking up this magical thing
by the way you are not only [ __ ]
because you're not gonna be able to use
it because you don't have an iPhone you
take child me into the future
let's do with that we bring child me in
the future and sit down all my favorite
toys you're winning
he's so cute don't hurt him yeah he
wants to play with that I don't care
what else you put in front of a matter
how many much family attack
who cares what my parents are saying I
would steal on a toy yeah probably get
sick of pretty quickly if I may that's
their problem you know christmas is
coming up I'm whining I'm doing whatever
it takes to get that thing I think $0.99
is a better option and using your own
imagination rather than using yeah I
want to control some factor we are with
the purchase of a pizza correct before
time guys coming up on screen I'm just
gonna go ahead and say that your choices
aren't as good as mine
because I I think I think the Land
Before Time guys as fun as it is to
anally violated dinosaur there are only
there's so many adventures you can have
with dudes on your fingers yeah here we
go
imagination and male ground there there
is a picture of my limb before time guys
in my firehouse we've had somewhere to
be I'm gonna I'm gonna poke holes in you
in your guys I'm not gonna defend mine
because I think my explanation of mine
which is that it enables the imagination
to do things that are more fun is I just
stick by that explanation and I'm sure
you guys will poke holes in it but it
did I believe can you fact check that I
think the firehouse came with a guy I
will see what came also by the way when
I was when I was little
this was a [ __ ] spaceship so all I
needs the house but but anything be a
house no the house the house from well
then by that logic no toys are necessary
to play in your house yes yeah okay so
to by itself I think by itself I can put
anything in there and it'll be just as
fun where as a toy by himself he can go
on adventures in them but poke these
holes hold if yours anally violated
dinosaurs not that fun in in perpetual
and and yours the big problem of the
bb-8 is number one you need an iphone to
control it
number two I haven't seen that movie
none of us have number three priced
number number four it's very cool but so
are a million other things okay well
we're not comparing anything that
anything goes wasn't cheap in the day
either $50 and you didn't need another
component take it worth wow I look up
the price I can't tell you that the fire
house did not include an actually figure
but it did include slime that you could
pour
so yeah now you have a slimey house oh
boy how do you think those guys got me
into that man building slimy house yeah
I mean I'm I take issue to the fact that
we're signing like social responsibility
to these toys like they need to be
affordable to everyone they need to
encourage imagination this is just cool
in a vacuum it's magic you don't know
how it works it works with the
technology we have of today that you
need to operate
stop trying to Lucas this this is not a
midi-chlorian thing tell me how this
works I don't want to know how it's
magic magic but what do you do with it
you patrol for a little while you make
it turn around you show off your friends
and they get all this this thing is on a
shelf in a month yeah exactly it'll lose
its fun after it oh wow you know I'm
gonna need to do something in line for
the force awakens so you make it rhyme
Jenkins will be fun and then the force
awakens comes out anyway so you've got a
wild imagination but like you're further
kids they're just stuck in the
Ghostbusters house like they want to
leave and go on adventures how many
different things this can be like oh hi
Janine like hey hey guys your life right
and little kids will have all the
opportunity they need to go in
adventures once they put away the bb-8
because they have the internet on their
iPhone that they need to have yeah Land
Before Time toys yeah once you can use
with your imagination when I was a kid I
didn't think about being old stuff I was
just having a great time with Petrie and
Spike and you know baby I think you just
lose it'll lose its fun quickly it's
really fun to have right this second
because it's the hot thing of the moment
but give it a month or two I think it'll
be whatever
the ghost house is awesome but you just
need a toy to play in it dan yes any
thoughts - Anibal I try and gather I
can't wait to hear what the answer our
price of ghost house please
I cannot I looked I cannot find the
original I'll tell you it's probably
neighborhood of $50 that's a billion
dollars but thanks Obama
no sorry so no no but so price of a
Peter Venkman action figure six dog I
did find that the figures retail for
it's $5.99 yeah so I mean like come on
all right and you don't even have to go
to Domino's but she had to go for five
based on the arguments I didn't think
this one would win but I think Spencer
he really could argument with which one
would you put if you have these three
toys here with the kid gravitate toward
and it is magic it is completely true
everything you see you just have the toy
on the table but it ain't even a game
were like a kid you're right it just
it's like how are they doing that and
the fact that it's there I didn't
realize it we were including an iPhone
in our office I'm sure your Liam Falcon
yours still needs arms anyway anything
can be a toy not anything can be an
iPhone true right it also works on
Android it also - I lost okay good
Spencer's right good argument I give it
to Spencer thank you
yeah you were Chicago without them there
that's the problem I know I know he's a
lot smaller really really that bb-8 toys
a piece of [ __ ] free ones look at it
maybe I'll be convinced if I would
Spencer points one Alicia to max I'm
sorry Alicia that knocks you out
you always bring it thank you for coming
this was an intense episode that was
really fun thanks a hot time it was
great so we're here at the speed round
Max and Spencer are gonna go in we are
going to go to speed round one quick
more round from our sponsor I want to
thank Luke rate once again as always go
to loot crate comm slash movie fights
use code movie fights to save 10% on a
new subscription sign up by September
19th to receive September's summoner
create some and create with items from
Blizzard Kidrobot and more and that
special item they said is amazing dan
had some fantastic items from last month
as you know so please support our show
and loot crate and go use that promo
code move flights link in the
description below on youtube and if
you're listening on itunes it's loot
crate comm slash movie fights alright
i'm having a lot of fun thank you for
inviting me come on this is Max's first
time he didn't have as much that he
prepared you knows he's passionate I
love it when I'm passionate I get yelled
at it's like you do you think I don't
get yelled at thank you you all brought
it but I love the passion and I let
sometimes it's hard to let people talk
him got it
you've been very fair they've all been
fairs have been a very fun match I thank
everybody and thanks for coming all of
you so now let's get to the speed around
we tested this with you earlier so you
know how to do this I'm shocked
you're one point down the trademark is
melting down during the tides can turn
very quickly but again fast quick
answers we track we practice this that's
hard for me it's a chance to win the
five more points if again if you say the
same answer at the same time I go with
whoever said it first and then you'll
have to quickly pick a second choice any
questions I'm so [ __ ] I'm so [ __ ]
all right a phrase another question
let's start to speed around all right
who would be the best director for a
remake of the movie speed [ __ ] can I can
i I don't want to say it's because I'm
gonna be offensive because I'm gonna
mess up his name Christo and directed
snowpiercer there we go pumpkin thank
you I'm Jenna and Christopher Nolan all
right we heard but you were saying
bonding for someone who can go ahead
Spencer he's I'm a clock and go when
you're ready - yep that's only if we
both say Chris okay yeah we good and go
ahead so with snowpiercer and the
hosting in certain parts he's proven he
can take a single long extended action
sequence and give it character and give
it a depth and give it fill it with new
surprises which is what speed really is
wait why are we saying it's okay to
reboot speed we should never max your
shot Nolan take go ahead totally Batman
Begins is similar to speed when no one's
funny he's very funny he needs to
reinvent himself and his image he's a
master of action and caught an
uncompromised plotlines leveling them
and following many things at once I
believe he could maintain momentum
throughout the entire movie do an
amazing job and it would be good for his
career Wow 5 second rebuttal Spencer you
don't with speed as a simple movie
Christopher Nolan's gonna stuff it full
of plot and twists and and CGI alright
you went up topic I'm gonna give you
five seconds to that bomb John who does
the same in every one of his movies
snowpiercer is totally inconsistent
bizarre and incoherent despite being a
fun movie
all right I think I you gave away you
gave up sort of halfway through it so
I'm gonna get the points of max I don't
even speed it's movie Fight special I'm
gonna fight I'm giving up after the fact
three two three all right question to
both of these movies are playing on
cable which one should we watch The
Mummy three Tomb of the Dragon Emperor
or Jurassic Park three Joseph work three
mummy three Jurassic Park is first
all right thing one second time on the
clock and go ahead Spencer Jurassic Park
3 is not the worst Jurassic Park sequel
it's a generic movie but it's still a on
the surface entertaining one you get
dinosaurs you got people running away
from dinosaurs it's better than Brendan
Fraser running around The Mummy if he's
even still in it at that point he is
okay all right time on the clock for Max
and go ahead I agree 100% that you're a
spark three is not a bad movie that said
The Mummy three is one of the worst
movies I've ever seen it's completely
incoherent if you are watching it on
cable it is amazing yetis play football
yetis play football it's so bad it's
amazing people don't talk about it it's
one of those movies it's worth watching
if you got nothing else to do surprise I
say five-second you said it was
miserable and incoherent I don't that's
not I want to spend my time all right
that was off-topic and maybe five
seconds final would you rather spend
your time with something incoherent and
insane or something mediocre mediocre
you're wrong would you open up the
floodgates now I think max didn't come
together made a fan that fascinating eye
stances I didn't think I would but I'm
giving it to him add and as to chime in
I gotta say that last argument I would
rather see something unusually
incoherent than mediocre so I gotta go
four to three now matches in the lead
ready that's how it happens here I'm
scared
number three please name the best movie
with girl or girls in the title Girl
Interrupted okay Spencer yeah I could it
was the first one I can actually I think
five seconds I hate to girl or girls
girls night out great not gone girl oh
yeah that's good girls gone out okay go
ahead max Girl Interrupted is a better
movie than girls night out it has strong
performances it's evocative it's
emotional it was a think piece for a
generation that holds up today Angelina
Jolie is also smoking hot in it as this
Winona Ryder it's a smart fun
compassionate movie about something
serious and it's worth you seeing all
right Spencer let's hear your argument
girls night out is a smart ensemble
comedy Melissa McCarthy at the top of
her game this is like Porky's in Reverse
this is really just a fantastic film
that's way on the radio it's way
underrated the scene the scene with the
with the ham sandwich is amazing Connect
connect put a stop
[Laughter]
and we almost fell for it have to get
these two it's a tie
the time okay what's the better movie
location to visit better movie location
abysm giving you two choices ready max
Harry Potter's Hogwarts or Star Wars is
Jedi Temple a pride of Hogwarts a temple
wait Star Wars Jedi Temple where where
is that like you haven't yeah where they
gather with Yoda right wait like Ryback
should we get to go there like it's a
real webs if you're gonna go as a real
place which one would you go to you just
got to do the J attempt Oh Jedi Temple
great so you're gonna argue that
Hogwarts ready for time in the clock
ready go ahead ok the Jedi Temple is a
fantastic place to take a nap everyone
there is sitting around stroking their
chin and just like pontificating on the
nature of the force Hogwarts is full of
fun adventure and literal magic if you
include Diagon Alley its you can do
anything and meet anyone there
where's jet ok not for you muggle you'd
be dead in your first five minutes
kicked out or having your mind wiped to
go to Hogwarts as muggle would be the
least fun shortest experience you'll
never remember ever the Jedi Temple is
open to the public and you can learn
things about the history of the New and
Old Republic's I'm very excited to go
there especially because a lot tap in
there are you are you Voldemort like
locals are allowed in there no they're
not a magical they're allowed in there
they
all right I need a fact check I need to
check this squibs that are allowed in
Hogwarts he is not a muggle she is a
stud blood is different this is just a
visit it's not to go to hug where can't
visit muggles cannot okay they can bring
a muggle in muggles and the Goblet of
Fire that's really gonna affect the
charm i nee explains that muggles cannot
see Hogwarts Hogwarts happy witch if a
muggle looks at it all they see is
really fun time we have never seen it
happen we have never heard of it
happening the only person without
magical powers in Hannon alright alright
this is tough because are we allowing
magic to let a muggle in is what we're -
having it go anywhere or because I'm
because that really didn't is the
defining point so I'm gonna ask you a
question if you couldn't visit there is
a tremendous amount of there is a
tremendous amount of racism towards
muggles in the magical world that we see
repeated again and again people who are
even born into mobile families they've
got a good argument so I'm gonna have
you help it's a good argument but like
you said the question was asked well
assuming they can get in there so on
that basis alone your argument was more
fun it's Dan and Alicia tell me who's
what I said I'm because we asked the
question we're allowing and assuming
there's some magic way that you could
get in there so while your argument was
fine I can't have a dog work sorry you
can't get in don't get killed but I'm
gonna say based on those two arguments
II had originally I'm gonna go with more
fun and the things he said first and I
thought he did a better knock down yeah
well yeah go ahead cuz I I think he
thought outside of the box so I would go
with max because he that was he brought
up a good point so I would I would
choose max yeah arguments I'd go with
Matt all right let alone pester closes
it closes it max wins the game
I think it's a fair call mix wins the
game
Wow I would have chosen Hogwarts too but
I realized the second the second he said
it I was like when have we ever seen a
muggle and huh wait they hate muggle
always a trick question you guys I tried
I tried to give it to you on a visit all
right that was amazing thank you guys
max thanks for coming man yes come back
anytime we're fan I'm so glad you got
here Spencer wow you brought it you're
on it very close you always bring it I'm
always grateful thanks for coming let's
plug your things actually let's do that
I'm doing this at Spencer gate J Gilbert
right do they are great Thank You max
anything else you'd like to plug here
there we go my next my next thing that's
like coming out is mr. right is a movie
I wrote is closing Toronto Film Festival
so I guess you guys can't see it but
it's it's probably probably one of my
favorites other than Chronicle but uh
you know the screenwriter what can you
promote you can't promise anything about
the movie see right you can't promise
anything that's coming out go see that
give me some money
i am i Superman comic is the best that
is the most exciting thing they're all
they're like I can't wait and just
follow me on Twitter and I'll keep you
updated and you're very active I love it
you talk to me too active I don't have a
publicist and no one tells me not to
engage with trolls Alicia Alicia Malone
and Alicia Malone
tell us about profiles and everything
else where can we see you yeah you can
see profiles every second week on
popcorn top Network we just did a great
episode on Dustin Hoffman looking
forward to what we've got coming up next
plus you can check out my own youtube if
you like movies on my jam thank you guys
for having me that was so much fun thank
you Dan Merle and the Dan cam at Merle
Dan anything you'd like to plugged in
ironically the star of Victor
Frankenstein Daniel Radcliffe
the star of the victim Victor Vegas to
Mary Potter Thank You April on your
Twitter April searching dawn
thanks for Jeff fun I had so much fun
awesome thank you for coming and thank
you for being a fan and thank you for
dealing all those mean people let's be
nice people please be nice to people I
always like to say and I'm a nice
ignoring singer now before we go I just
want to say next week is guy it's
actually tough because you did a
fantastic show but next week we're gonna
have another fantastic show Elijah Wood
stuff it's so much it's gonna be so much
fun we're so excited I'm so happy to
announce it so get excited next week for
Elijah Wood but I'm still excited that
Mac Slater's here thanks again for
coming please come back and now we will
see you guys next time every podcast we
put on YouTube comes with this kick-ass
graphic listing all the topics your
favorite screen junkies podcasters are
talking about if you click the topics
you can skip around and choose your own
podcast battle royale go ahead try them
all if you haven't already subscribe to
scream junkies on YouTube to join us for
future fights or if you prefer to listen
on iTunes click the logo to download an
audio version
you